- [Instructor] Hey, have you ever seen
this kind of plant before?
It's called a dandelion.
If you live in a tropical
climate, it might be unfamiliar,
but if you live in a more temperate zone,
you'll probably recognize it
as it's a very common plant.
Dandelions make yellow flowers
that develop into balls
of these fluffy white seed
heads that fly off the plant.
This can happen by a gust of wind,
by animals spreading them,
or even by someone blowing on the plant.
When this happens, it
seeds fly into the air
and land on new spots on the ground.
From there, the seeds can
grow into new dandelions,
starting the whole cycle over.
But why do dandelions do this?
Why do they turn into puff balls?
Why are they yellow?
If they don't have brains,
how do they seem to know
when to release their seeds?
These are all complicated questions.
But to begin answering them,
we can talk about what influences
the growth and development
of dandelions and in
turn all living things.
So what determines how
a dandelion will grow?
Its genes and its environment.
Let's take a moment to
review what genes are.
Genes make up the hereditary material
inside an organism cells.
Genes provide the information
about what traits an organism has.
So the reason that our
dandelion has yellow pedals
and develops fluffy white seed heads
lies within its genes.
Any influence genes have on
the way an organism grows
is called a genetic factor.
So if one dandelion has
more seeds than another
as a result of which version
of a certain gene it has,
we can say that the
difference in seed number
is due to a genetic factor.
The other major influence
on how a dandelion grows
is its environment.
But what makes up an
organism's environment?
The environment is the set of conditions
an organism is exposed to during its life.
For a dandelion, this
includes temperature,
how much light and water it gets,
and which nutrients
are present in the soil
where it grows.
Any influence the environment
has on an organism's growth
is called an environmental factor.
So if one dandelion plant
is exposed to more sunlight
than another and grows
bigger, as a result,
we can say that the difference is due
to an environmental factor.
But plants aren't the
only living organisms
that are motivated by these factors.
Animals are also influenced by
their genes and environment.
For example, let's look at dogs.
Dogs come in many different
shapes, sizes, colors,
and each have their own unique features.
We can see this when
looking at different breeds,
like pugs which are
small with squishy faces,
and golden retrievers,
which are large with
flowing locks of golden fur.
These traits are largely determined
by which genes each breed of dog has,
or in other words, by genetic factors.
But dogs are also influenced
by environmental factors too.
For instance, how much
food they get as they grow
helps determine their size,
and what they learn from other dogs,
and from people help
determine their behaviors.
Like when you teach your dog a new trick.
And now you know how
organisms are influenced
by genetics and their environment
when it comes to growth and development.
Let's do a quick review of
what you've learned today.
First, there are two main factors
that influence an organism's growth,
these are genetic and
environmental factors.
Genetic factors are the
genes the organism gets
from its parent or parents.
While environmental
factors are the conditions
and organism is exposed to as it grows.
These factors show that
all living organisms
have a couple things in common
even dogs and dandelions.
So while our interactions
with them may differ
like how you can't
teach a dandelion to sit
like you can with a dog,
both organisms experience
growth and development
through their own unique
genes and environments.